mes chers collègues nous ouvrons les
travaux de notre commission d'enquête en
recevant aujourd'hui le docteur Nicole
boy ainsi que messieur Christophe
Thierry le comte j'espère que j'aV j'ai
bien prononcé au titre du rapport qu'ils
ont rédigé pour le compte de
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales sur la qualité de l'accueil et
la prévention de la maltraitance dans
les crèches je rappelle aux collègues
présents que vous avez été missionné en
juillet 2022 par l'ancien ministité de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
Jean-Christophe combe à la suite du
drame survenu en juin de la même année
et de la mort dans une crèche du 3e
arrondissement de Lyon d'un bébé de 11
mois votre rapport a été remis au mois
de mars 2023 au vu de la large
mobilisation du secteur pour participer
à la consultation que vous avez mené au
vu également des constats dressés et des
préconisations que vous avez formulé ce
rapport ne pouvait demeurer sans suite
du point de vue de la représentation
nationale le 3 mai 2023 la délégation
aux droits des enfants de notre
assemblée auditionner trois d'entre vous
c'est à la suite de cette audition qui a
été décidé en septembre dernier la
création par la même délégation d'une
mission d'information sur les
perspectives d'évolution de la prise en
charge des enfants dans les crèches
alors que deux ouvrages étaient par
ailleurs publiés qui portaient plus plus
particulièrement sur les crèche privée
notre commission d'enquête qui s'inscrit
dans ce prolongement a souhaité vous
entendre au tout début de ses travaux
afin de pouvoir disposer d'une vue
d'ensemble sur le secteur des crèches
avant d'en étudier les diverses facettes
cette audition je le précise est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et
l'enregistrement vidéo sera ensuite
disponible à la demande madamees
messieurs je vous propose une brève
intervention liminaire d'une dizaine de
minutes tout au plus qui permett de
resituer les enjeux je laisserai ensuite
la parole à à la rapporteur nous
poursuivrons nos échanges avec les
représentants des groupes puis
l'ensemble des collègues souhaitant
intervenir sous la forme de
questions-réponse d'ors et déjà au vu du
temps qui nous est imparti j'invite
chacun à aller à l'essentiel
à ce stade il me reste à vous indiquer
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires qui
imposent aux personnes auditionnées par
une commission d'enquête de prêter le
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je vous invite
donc à lever la main droite et à dire je
le
jure je vous remercie et je vous laisse
tout de suite la parole les micros tour
de rôle parce que vous pourrez pas les
appuyer en même
temps bien titre introductif monsieur le
Président donc il s'agissait de conduire
une mission d'évaluation chargée de
d'apporter des éclaircissements quant
aux facteurs qui auraient pu concourir à
l'installation de T situations et donc
on allait au-delà du cas de la crèche de
Lyon qui était à l'origine de la mission
alors au sein du périmètre qui était le
sien donc je tiens à le rappeler c'était
les crèches collectives hors crèche
familiales et hors jardin d'enfants donc
la mission s'est attaché à déterminer
tous les facteurs qui peuvent concourir
à la qualité de l'accueil ou constituer
un risque de de dérive et de
maltraitance individuelle et
institutionnelle alors pour mener cette
mission nous donc la mission a duré les
investigations ont duré 4 mois nous
avons auditionné des acteurs nationaux
du secteur que ce soit des
administrations fédérations syndicats
gestionnaires chercheurs experts nous
sommes rendus dans huit départements
pour rencontrer les administrations
locales conduire les visites d'un
échantillon de hie nous sommes rendus
donc dans 36 établissements d'accueil
pour rencontrer les responsables les
professionnels et puis surtout c'était
le plus important prendre un temps
d'immersion parce qu'il s'agissait pas
juste de rester dans le bureau de la
directrice pour avoir un échange succin
donc d'immersion et d'observation auprès
des enfants nous avons par ailleurs
diffusé trois questionnair et ça c'était
un un élément important pour notre
rapport trois questionnaires l'un auprès
des directeurs d'établissement
l'autre auprès des professionnels qui
assurent l'accueil des enfants et enfin
le troisième auprès des parents et ces
questionnaires ont reçu respectivement
plus de 5000 réponses pour les
directeurs d'établissement plus de 12000
pour les professionnels et plus de 27000
pour les
parents alors ces questionnaires il faut
le préciser n'avit pas pour objet de
viser une représentativité statistique
parce que c'était pas le but il
s'agissait d'avoir un des éléments qui
nous permettent au qui nous permettent
d'éclairer les constats que nous
faisions nous-mêmes mais pour aller
au-delà de nos visites et avoir plus de
d'éléments de de terrain alors le nombre
de réponses témoigne d'une large
mobilisation du secteur qui a qui a
vraiment à tous les échelons chercher à
faciliter nos travaux et à répondre à
toutes nos
demandes je suis
fini en introduction je crois que voilà
on
peut vous êtes très efficace
euh on va donc avoir plus de temps pour
pour nos échanges moi j'ai j'ai j'ai une
première question liminaire vous avez
visité 8 département on le sait bien
dans dans dans le processus de de de
contrôle sur la qualité d'accueil la PMI
a un rôle essentiel est-ce que vous
pourriez euh nous indiquer euh si vous
avez observé euh des des des différences
d'approches euh dans le dans la manière
d'appréhender la qualité des différences
de critères euh et des suites pouvant
donner qui qui peuvent être donné
lorsqu'on a des problèmes de qualité en
fonction des
départements merci al non pardon euh
alors d'abord pour dire que euh il y a
des vraies disparités entre les
départements pas uniquement dans la dans
l'approche des PMI parce que les PMI ne
sont que aussi en regard de la situation
de de du département il y a une vraie
différence entre des départements
urbains et ruraux et aussi entre la
prévalence ou pas de de structur de
petite taille de de grosse taille de
territoirees urbains purbain de aussi de
niveau de niveau socio socio-économique
donc c'est c'est pour ça qu'on a
démultiplié les déplacements dans les
mesures de la mission pour essayer
d'appréhender vraiment toute la div cité
des établissements de la nature
juridique du de la taille des
établissement des publics accueilis et
de de
l'environnement et de l'environnement de
de ces établissements et effectivement
au sein des
PMI on a constaté des des différences
assez assez notoire à la fois bah dans
les moyens qui sont mobilisés parce que
tout dépend aussi des des moyens qui
sont mobilisés humains au sein au sein
des PMI pour pouvoir exercer exercer un
contrôle et et accompagner parce que on
parle beaucoup de contrôle mais c'est
aussi accompagner ces établissements
dans leurs difficultés ou dans leur leur
projets pédagogiqu donc on a constaté
des des des vraies
disparités en terme de en terme de
moyens en terme de de méthodologie et
c'est aussi dépendant des personnes qui
animent ces ces ces ces ces PMI qui
permettent ou pas d'avoir un contrôle
plus ou moins plus ou moins qualitatif
plus ou moins précis et encore une fois
face aussi à une volumétrie qui n'est
pas forcément identique d'un département
à une autre donc on vous dire que le que
les PMI c'est homogène sur le territoire
c'est ça serait une erreur et c'est
c'est assez hétérogène au regard de
l'hétérogénité aussi du
secteur je me permets en rebond après je
céderai la parole à la rapporteur vous
avez parlé prévalence urbain rurale
prévalence taille de structure et de de
j'allais dire des précarités sociales
qui peuvent exister euh est-ce qu'on a
plus de problèmes de qualité en milieu
urbain ou en milieu rural plus sur les
grandes structures que sur les petites
structur ure parce que je vous avez
évoqué des des des points en disant il y
a des prévalences très concrètement quel
est l'impact sur la qualité en fait les
problèmes de qualité sont vraiment
transversales on peut pas tirer de
signne égal si c'était le sens de votre
question ou d'essayer de circonscrire le
problème de de l'examen de la qualité ou
d'une qualité approfondie que ce soit
sur un statut public associatif ou privé
lucratif il y a des biais dans chacun on
pourrait revenir sur chacun des des de
ces statuts mais en tout cas il y a un
vrai problème systémique c'est pour ça
que pour rebondir ce que disait mon mon
collègue il y a une vraie attente du
secteur de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes pour que les choses soient
appréhendées et pour que ça bouge parce
que le problème est vraiment systémique
donc non il n'y a pas de on ne peut pas
dire voilà c'est plus compliqué dans une
grosse crèche une crèche de multiaccueil
d'importance avec des les de plus de 50
50 berceau ou dans une micro crèche il y
a des difficultés dans l'ensemble de ces
établissements qui s'expriment de
manière
différente et pas forcément liée à un
statut juridique ou une imp après
évidemment c'est plus compliqué quand on
est dans des quartiers difficiles quand
on est en ruralité par exemple pour les
communes c'est lié aussi beaucoup à la
capacité financière au-delà de la
question de la volonté politique de la
capacité financière des communes à
mobiliser des moyens sur la petite
enfance donc une commune qui a qui est
contrainte beaucoup sur ses ressources
aura des difficultés comme surensemble
ces politiques publiques à mobiliser des
moyens sur ces sur ces crèches
municipales comme une une collectivité
qui a des moyens plus importants va
pouvoir pour le coup
mobiliser des moyens supplémentaires
pour avoir des volants de de personnel
qui sont qui qui peuvent palier les
absences on y reviendra dans les
effectifs qui peuvent mobiliser du temps
de médecins des temps de psychologues
qui viennent conforter les équipes et
qui donc mettent de la mettent de la
qualité dans d'abord un P les
difficultés systémiques du secteur et de
mettre de la qualité dans dans l'accil
donc c'est c'est vraiment très en tout
cas on peut pas avoir de c'est toute la
complexité et tout l'intérêt d'allur de
vos travaux c'est c'est de vraiment
d'appréhender tout toutes les disparités
dans ce secteur et toutes les
particularités merci je passe désormais
la parole à la
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
tout d'abord quelques mots pour vous
remercier à toutes et tous d'être
présents aujourd'hui pour l'ouverture de
nos travaux euh si je suis très heureuse
d'être là rapporteur de cette commission
d'enquête j'ai conscience qu'il s'agit
d'un travail
collectif et sachez que vous trouverez
toujours ma porte ouverte pour échanger
des idées et des
propositions madame boic messieur Itier
et le conte je voulais je voudrais tout
d'abord commencer par vous remercier
d'avoir répondu favorablement à notre
demande d'audition et pour la qualité du
travail qui est le vôtre et que vous
avez retranscrit dans votre rapport
alors je vous interrogerai sur un
certain nombre d'éléments figurants dans
ce rapport ma première question est
celle-ci donc le recensement des alertes
est un élément central de toute
politique publique à forceorie lorsqu'il
s'agit du bien-être des enfants en
basâge votre rapport est édifiant à cet
égard il n'existe à proprement parler
aujourd'hui aucun circuit centralisé de
remonté d'information permettant de
signaler d'éventuelle violation de la
réglementation ou de signes de
maltraitance les PMI ne semblent pas
toujours ou alors de manière aléatoire
vous préconisez de faire identifier les
PMI par l'ensemble des acteurs
institutionnels et par les parents comme
le service responsable de centraliser
ses signalements par quel biais ont-ils
les ressources pour collecter les
informations mais surtout agir dans un
délai raisonnable quelles sont vos
préconisations pour faire évoluer le
contrôle exercé sur les eajie vers une
meilleure prise en compte de la qualité
d'accueil des jeunes enfants quelle
place pour les parents pour les communes
dans l'exercice pratique et quotidien de
ce contrôle ma seconde question vous
indiquez également donc je vous cite la
régulation insuffisante du secteur
marchand peut laisser prospérer des
stratégies économiques préjudiciables à
la qualité d'accueil vous pointez plus
précisément la baisse des dépenses de
personnel à rebours de l'augmentation
des salaires et des prix et
l'augmentation conséquente des comptes
autre charges dans les frais de siège de
groupe comment l'expliquez-vous
pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus
vous is enfin de restructurer les
financements publics afin d'en faire un
levier de qualité de la prise en charge
pouvez-vous nous préciser vos
propositions vous paraî-il pertinent
d'uniformiser les modalités de
financement public pourriez-vous nous
détailler vos propositions afin de
renforcer le contrôle financiers des
opérateurs et les éventuelles marges
cachées qui figurent dans les conditions
de financement de ces établissements
considérez-vous que cela passe
nécessairement par une
contractualisation de tous les acteurs
avec la puissance publique même
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un acteur privé qui
s'installe à son initiative je vous
remercie vous avez plusieurs questions
euh prenez le temps parce que les chaque
question est est très importante pour
nous et comme on démarre nos travaux on
veut vraiment partir de ce point de
départ de votre expertise et ensuite on
aura beaucoup d'auditions qui
suivont oui peut-être commencer par la
notion de de signalement et de contrôle
donc bah déjà les à la base il faut déjà
avoir une sensibilisation de l'ensemble
des personnes parce que dire qu'il y a
un problème il faut d'abord savoir que
les choses ne sont pas faites
correctement donc on a bien posé d'abord
cette cette problématique dans notre
rapport à savoir la connaissance des
besoins des jeunes enfants des jeunes
enfants c'est pas normal de de dans un
établissement par exemple il y avait un
un stagiaire auquel il était interdit de
prendre un enfant dans les bras voilà en
2023 hein donc quelque part il y a déjà
la connaissance du besoin de l'enfant
donc le les les on est on est on est
vous nous aviez aussi préparé à avoir ce
type de question en se disant comment on
a évolué dans la connaissance des
besoins des enfants donc je parle là
d'un stagiaire mais les parents aussi
quel qu quelles attentes on a par
rapport à l'accompagnement qui va être
apporté à notre enfant et et et entre
professionnel comment on va pouvoir
aussi repérer que ce qui se fait là ce
qui se pratique n'est pas une bonne
pratique donc vous voyez on a on a
vraiment il faut que tout tout un chacun
et puisse avoir cette l'accès à cette
connaissance la connaissance des besoins
fondamentaux alors on est à l'Assemblée
nationale on peut penser à Madame veille
en 78 c'est c'est pas si loin que ça en
moi ça me fait pas trop loin peut-être
que d'autres ça paraît plus loin mais
qui travailler sur la question de des
des pouponnières et avec un il y avait
un film qui avait été extrêmement
intéressant qui montrait la gravité he
des atteintes physiques et mentales des
enfants en manque d'affection hein tout
simplement et manque d'activité d'éveil
et on voyait à quel point les personnes
qui s'occupaient de ces enfants était
parfaite en
technicité mais il n'y avait pas la
relation euh affective la relation voilà
donc
c'est les tous les travaux qui qui qui
traitent de la question de la sécurité
affective de l'enfant date déjà des
années 60 et ils ont été repris et on a
un travail très intéressant et très
important qui a été fait dans notre pays
à partir des des de plusieurs chercheurs
et puis qui ont pris aussi de la une
mesure politique à travers les la la
charte hein donc pour l'accueil des des
des des jeunes enfants qu'ils soient à
domicile ou que chez les ou ou dans les
crèches et donc euh la les travaux donc
permettent de de de de remettre au
centre les besoins de l'enfant donc on n
pas on n'est pas sans éléments mais ils
ne sont sincèrement ils sont très peu
encore entrés dans la dans le
fonctionnement le problème que l'on va
mettre donc en avant par rapport au
notion de de signalement c'est donc
d'abord la connaissance des besoins de
l'enfant la connaissance pour les
professionnels ça passe par les
formations et on a clairement posé la
problématique des des CAP alors il y a
des gens extraordinaire dans toutes les
professions hein donc voilà mais là on
voit bien que ce sont très souvent de
très jeunes al ce sont surtout des
jeunes filles qui étaient en difficulté
scolaire qui avaient des difficultés à
trouver leur voix on leur dit vous
pouvez vous occuper de bébés vous faites
une formation en ligne vous faites un
stage qui n'est pas validant
c'est-à-dire que les directeurs nous
disait je ressens que pour cette jeune
fille c'est encore trop compliqué pour
elle de s'occuper d'enfant un enfant pas
un bébé par nature ça n'est pas euh une
personne qui va vous valoriser tout de
suite hein ça c'est c'est voilà il y a
ça peut être ingrat ça peut être
difficile ça peut être compliqué donc ça
n'est pas facile c'est pas un métier
facile et donc on a beaucoup de
professionnels qui ont des formations
qui sont insuffisamment encadrées qui
sont validé à partir d'avoir fait
quelques stages sans pour autant avoir
de
le
d'évaluation sérieuse et donc donc le
c'est pour ça que pour parler avant de
parler contrôle parler alerte je crois
que c'est vraiment important mais pour
alerter et on l'a vu à travers nos
questionnaires aussi nous nous voyons
bien que là où les les établissements
qui ont répondu aux questions
questionnaire on a eu beaucoup plus de
remonté de description de choses qui ne
vont pas là où il y avait des gens
formés parce qu'ils sont formés donc ils
savent dire que ça ne va pas hein qu'il
y a des choses qu'il faut reprendre que
et cetera
donc je pense que c'est le premier point
je suis c'est un petit peu long
peut-être mon mon le dérouler de cette
présentation mais je crois que c'est
très important déjà d'avoir ce cette
notion
là de la connaiss des besoins de
l'enfant et donc savoir qu'on a des
outils déjà par exemple la charte la
charte c'est 10 principes ils sont très
très bien posé respect du rythme de
l'enfant de la place de ses parents de
la du besoin de la mobilité combien de
fois on a entendu dans les crèche on ne
court pas dans la crèche alors quand
vous voyez les pédiatres il vous
explique un enfant d'un an et demi il
tient son équilibre en courant donc et
mais oui mais comme c'est très exigu que
tous les enfants sont un peu mélangés
voilà donc bon mais voilà donc ces 10
principes
et la la charte elle est bien plus plus
intéressante que simplement les 10
principes c'est un arrêté et qui est
resté sous forme d'arrêté alors pas
beaucoup de parents vont lire un arrêté
pour avoir le détail de ce que ce qu'on
entend derrière respect du rythme
respect de et donc il y a déjà ce qu'on
le dit déjà dans notre rapport de de
pouvoir présenter ces éléments déjà de
autrement que seulement à travers un
arrêté mais les les les valoriser auprès
des parents et cetera donc voilà pour ce
qui est de de du repérage de la
compréhension de ce que vivent les
enfants et puis ensuite le contrôle le
contrôle ça cela commence par déjà une
culture de l'erreur au sein des
établissements on a voilà ce sont des
gens donc très souvent des des
professionnels qui qui ont des des
niveaux de formation assez assez peu
élevés qui sont qui se trouvent en
difficulté et qui ont la crainte hein de
perdre le travail et cetera donc il faut
travailler comme on l'a travaillé dans
le champ sanitaire médico-social la
culture de l'erreur pouvoir dire à sa
collègue écoute là ça ne va pas
peut-être que tu as besoin de prendre un
peu l'air je te sens voilà tendu voilà
donc le à suite à notre rapport on a vu
en effet parfois des des écrits disant
oui ben nous chez nous c'est zéro
tolérance hein donc de toute manière
s'il y a un problème on remercie la
personne je pense que vraiment c'est
c'est bien sûr il faut regarder la la
responsabilité individuelle il y a des
personnes qui font des choses très
graves et cetera ça c'est important mais
en tant qu'employeur on voit doit
d'abord regarder qu'est-ce qui a fait
que ça a pu se produire et qu'est-ce qui
fait que il y a il y a il y a eu des
difficultés donc le voilà les les points
un point très important c'est d'abord de
pouvoir travailler la dans dans d'avoir
des référentiels de savoir d'avoir la
savoir voir vraiment qu'est-ce comment
on travaille auprès d'enfant pouvoir du
coup s'auto réguler en parler en équipe
le remonter au au responsabl et autant
que nécessaire parce que voilà il faut
passer les étapes savoir que la la
culture et la compréhension de la façon
dont on s'occupe des enfants concerne
complètement les directeurs aussi on a
eu beaucoup de commentaire où il était
noté la directrice est passée nous a dit
que et cetera et et donc ça pose voilà
il faut vraiment aller tous les à tous
les niveaux parce que c'était aussi ah
bah vous savez moi j'ai bien claquer mes
enfants ils vont bien voilà donc voilà
donc c'est il y a pas de voilà c'est
très important mais on a eu des des
témoignages je suis désolée mais voilà
c'était de ce niveau et et donc voilà la
le cheminement de la de l'alerte de la
de c'est d'avoir d'avoir sensibiliser
tout le monde et sensibiliser tout le
monde c'est justement aussi dire aux aux
professionnels quand leur direction
leurs responsables ne réagissent pas par
rapport à à une une remontée
d'information de savoir que la PMI est
joignable donc on a vraiment demandé à
ce que dans tous les les établissements
le numéro de la PMI locale soit soit
affiché soit communiqué à tous les
professionnels et soit aussi communiqué
à tous les parents al il s'agit pas de
de dire il faut appeler voilà mais c'est
de dire si vous n'avez pas pu ent le
travailler avec vos collègues ni avec
vos responsables et cetera et vous vous
pouvez à tout moment appeler aussi la la
PMI et pareil pour les parents d'abord
travailler avec les personnes qui
s'occupent de l'enfant responsables et
cetera et savoir que voilà donc on a on
a rappelé le chemin le plus le plus
simple le plus local en fait parce que
la la la PMI
voilà alors il y a des numéros qu'on
trouve pas toujours facilement mais
celui-ci on le trouve bien quand on fait
des tests un peu sur internet on trouve
les les les numéros mais il faut
l'afficher voilà et
euh juste pour compléter sur sur cet
aspect contrôle signalement faut faut
comprendre qu'il y a évidemment la PMI
qui a la capacité de contrôle mais il y
a aussi la CAF puisque que la CAF a un
lien alors plus économique avec avec les
structures he au travers notamment quand
elle le finance mais mon collègue
viendra sur les modes de financement qui
répond à vos questions sur le modèle
économique euh puisqu'on a deux modes de
financement qui sont la la PSU la
prestation sociale unique et et la page
qui qui crée des liens organiques
différents avec les établissements
puisque quand on est pour faire très
simple en page on solvabilise la demande
donc les parents et donc le lien avec la
de la CAF est avec les parents alors que
quand on est en PSU la CAF finance
l'établissement et donc là on a un lien
organique financier un fluide un flu de
de financement avec l'établissement et
que donc la CAF a aussi la capacité de
contrôler euh sauf qu'elle contrôle sur
des enjeux de facturation sur des enjeux
économiques mais a des données de fait
économiques qui peuvent intéresser le
travail de la PMI notamment par exemple
sur le taux je
dirais normal de dépenses en consommable
en couche en alimentation et dès lors on
peut se dire voilà B là on est dans une
crèche qui est en ça ou auudessus des
critères il y a aussi des crèches où ça
va mieux mais pour une crèche où on voit
que les consommables notamment par
exemple la consommation de couche est en
dessous d'un d'un d'une moyenne normale
de consommation on peut se dire là il y
a peut-être une alerte de dans les les
comportements les le fonctionnement
d'une crèche et de la et de la même
façon pour les pour les PMI on voit que
le contrôle bâtimentaire a pris
énormément de
place et que bien souvent dans ce que
nous on a vu des rapports de contrôle
des PMI on est beaucoup sur le bâtiment
sur le bâti ce qui est important la
sécurité des enfants passe d'abord par
des bâtiments qui permettent de
sécuriser les enfants et assez peu
finalement marginalement sur le projet
pédagogique sur le la la manière dont la
la crèche
fonctionne vis-à-vis du projet du projet
éducatif ou ou du fonctionnement ou
l'accompagnement des enfants et donc il
y a il y a à la fois dans dans ce que
nous nous avons essayé de mettre en
avant en terme de d'amélioration du
signalement du contrôle c'est d'une part
d'avoir cette culture du besoin de
l'enfant qui aujourd'hui il y a pas n
pas assz c'est partagé y compris par les
parents qui perçoivent beaucoup on a
échangé avec eux notamment avec les
parents dans les immersions qui venaient
déposer leurs enfants ou les ver
chercher on est beaucoup dans un mode de
garde d'ailleurs ce que nous disent les
professionnels c'est qu'il ne supportent
plus qu'on leur dise amusez-vous bien
parce que on a ils ont l'impression
qu'on dévalorise qu'on ne reconnaît pas
l'importance de leur profession dans des
moments pourant stratégiques du
développement de l'enfant et donc il y a
il y a aussi un changer de regard sur
ces établissements qui ne sont pas que
des modes de garde qui qui ont une
vocation de de de répondre à des besoins
des familles de de de d'avoir des des
des solutions pour pour leurs enfants
pour reprendre une vie professionnelle
ou une formation et ça c'est extrêmement
important mais il faut rééquilibrer ça
en remettant aussi plus au centre les
besoins de l'enfant ça c'est un premier
élément d'où les idées de référentiel
deuxièmement faire travailler les
acteurs du contrôle ensemble en d'un
côté la PI de l'autre côté la CAF et ça
existe dans certaines dans certaines
régions c'est pour ça qu'on a été en
haute de Savoie où la CAF et la PMI
travaillent ensemble pour justement
avoir une une vision partagée sur sur
sur sur le sujet et puis ce qu'a dit mon
collègue ensuite c'est ma collègue
pardon c'est de donner de l'information
aux parents davantage d'information aux
parents et là c'est compliqué avait été
évoqué par exemple la question de mettre
en place un Conseil de parents dans
chaque établissement de la vie des
professionnels c'est très difficile on
voit bien déjà dans les écoles c'est
déjà compliqué mais dans une crèche oou
bien souvent c'est perçu encore une fois
qu' une notion de service on n' pas le
temps je renvoie chacun à à son
comportement en tant que parent euh on
n' pas le temps on est on doit déposer
le petit le grand euh le petit à la
crèche le grand à l'école on n' pas le
temps d'échanger finalement c'est assez
réduit et s'investir dans la
vieétablissement c'est très compliqué
pour euh pour les parents c'est très
compliqué pour les établissement de de
même en démultipliant les voilà des des
des choses plus informelles sans être
dans un conseil de parents c'est très
compliqué d'amener les parents à
s'intéresser à la vie d'établissant donc
il y a vraiment un changement de regard
presque de société sur les sur les sur
les crèches pour pour qu'on puisse
sortir les établissements de de leur
difficultés peut-être sur les
oui sur le volet économique et financier
mais juste avant pour compléter ce que
disaient mes collègues sur le volet
contrôle on voit qu'il y a plusieurs
acteurs qui peuvent intervenir mais qui
se coordonnent pas forcément euh certes
il y a la PMI il y a la CAF euh mais on
a vu qu'il pouvait y avoir aussi à la
marge d'autres acteurs intéressants euh
comme la DGC enfin les services en
région de la DGCCRF et puis surtout le
aussi l'inspection du travail puisque
les conditions de travail des personnels
en crèche sont si importantes et et pour
nous il était important de valoriser le
rôle du comité départemental de service
aux familles qui peut être l'instance au
niveau départemental pour que tous ces
acteurs qui sont départementaux puissent
se parler et notamment
confronter leurs observations dans telle
ou telle structure de manière à ce que
les autres puissent aussi être vigilant
sur ces structures sur le modèle
économique donc comme a commencé à à le
dire mon collègue on est sur un système
assez complexe et euh et peu lisible
aujourd'hui euh puisque le financement
des EAG repose sur deux dispositifs
concurrents alors le modèle de droit
commun c'est celui de la prestation de
service unique la PSU euh qui repose sur
un un tiers financeur donc pour la PSU
alors premierre premier financeur donc
la branche
famille 2èe financeur les parents et le
financement cumulé de la branche famille
et des parents ne doit pas excéder 66 %
du coût de revient horaire alors le
complément est versé par ce que l'on
appelle le tiers financeur et ce tiers
financeur alors classiquement ce sont
des communes bien souvent mais on peut
trouver aussi euh d'autres personnes
publiques ou des entreprises qui vont
réserver des
berceaux et puis à côté de ça nous avons
le modèle dérogatoire qui est ouvert au
microcèche et qui repose sur un
versement d'une allocation aux familles
qui paye directement l'établissement
donc là c'est pas la c'est pas la CAF
qui va verser à l'établissement euh la
CAF n'a pas de lien avec l'établissement
ce sont les parents qui reçoivent une
aide et qui ensuite vont vont financer
euh par ailleurs les des des entreprises
des personnes publiques peuvent
également réserver des places
euh et donc dans ce cas de figure en
effet les contrôles CAF et bien
euh n'interviennent pas puisque la CAF
ne finance pas directement
l'établissement
euh par ailleurs si les établissements
qui sont financés à la PSU représentent
enfin représenté au moment de la mission
89 % de l'offre d'accueil collective euh
la dynamique de création de nouvelles
places et nettement du côté des micro
crèches financé donc par la page
pourquoi parce que ça
permet ça permet de ne pas avoir de
tiers financeur et et aussi il faut
s'interroger sur le développement des
microocèches d'un côté et le
désengagement finalement des communes de
l'autre parce que ça permet de créer des
places de crèche sans que un tiers
financeur
intervienne donc voilà très succintement
après je crois que peut-être il peut
être intéressant de de retracer les les
raisons de ce mode de financement
puisque je crois que c'était aussi une
de vos questions dans le
questionnaire la PSU quelle était quel
était son intérêt c'était d'abord un
objectif de un paiement au plus près du
besoin des familles puisque il
s'agissait de faire payer aux familles
uniquement le service dont elle avait
besoin par rapport à un système
forfaitaire qui conduisait à payer pour
une journée ou une demi-journée or là
c'est c'est à l'heure donc on paye
vraiment en fonction du du temps du
temps passé mais donc c'est beaucoup
plus complexe à décomter et puis c'est
pour ça que les familles badge en
arrivant dans la crèche en partartant
puisque on doit décompter et regarder
combien combien d'heures ont été ont été
utilisés et puis de l'autre côté il
s'agissait d'augmenter la productivité
des établissements par une augmentation
du taux de fréquentation c'était le but
justement on nétait pas au forfait et
donc avec les heures c'est essayer de
remplir puisque une famille va pas
forcément utiliser toute la journée et
donc le but était là et donc elle avait
pour pour objet d'optimiser l'activité
des établissements et de ne pas laisser
des places vides lorsque les enfants ne
venaient que quelques heures mais cet
objectif on a vu qu'il a été que
partiellement atteint et finalement bon
cet objectif n'a pas été rempli et à
côté de ça on a malgré tout un système
extrêmement complexe et donc ça faisait
partie des des points qui avaient été
pointés par la Mission maintenant comme
l'objet de la mission n'était pas
d'aller très loin et d'expertiser
absolument le modèle économique puisque
nous on se notre angle d'approche
premier c'était la qualité puisque
c'était ça qui était essentiel donc nous
sommes allés sur le modèle économique
pour comprendre les difficulté mais nous
avons renvoyé ensuite éventuellement à
des travaux complémentaires qui pourent
être menés soit par une autre mission
que nous avons préconisé ou d'autres
travaux par ailleurs on ne pouvait pas
non plus aller sur des contrôles de
groupe puisque nous n'avions pas le le
pouvoir à
l'époque donc no nos investigations
étaient limitées
voilà voilà ce qu'on peut
direement merci je je vais laisser à la
rapporteur le soin de recompléter de
rebondir j'invite mes collègues qui
souhaitent intervenir après à se
signaler pour qu'on puisse organiser
ensuite les
questions
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
pour ces éléments de
réponse alors je crois comprendre de la
réponse que vous nous avez formulé euh
que
peut-être les précisions que je
sollicitait sur la nature des des
charges des EAG ne faisait pas parti
forcément du champ que vous aviez
exploré donc si c'est le cas euh je je
je retire ma question ou du moins je
pense que si vous êtes pas en mesure de
préciser c'est c'est c'est quelque chose
que nous examinerons par la suite en
revanche je voulais éventuellement vous
entendre à
nouveau sur la question de l'évolution
selon vous à l'ône de l'étude que vous
avez fait des travaux que vous avez
menés euh selon vous vers quelles
évolutions on doit aller sur le
financement public dans un objectif
effectivement d'avoir euh du financement
qui soit le plus vertueux possible en
vue d'une prise en charge des enfants de
0 à 3 ans qui soi non seulement euh qui
apporte des garanties sur le plan de la
sécurité de l'enfant mais qui euh
également permettent effectivement son
développement optimal sur une un moment
de la vie dont on sait qu'il est
structurant et essentiel pour le
développement de de cet être en devenir
alors avant même d'aller sur le le mode
de financement qui finalement est plutôt
une conséquence du modèle que l'on veut
avoir il y avait un autre point qui pour
nous est important c'était le la
question de de l'encadrement et du taux
d'encadrement puisque c'est c'est une
fois qu'on a défini le besoin que l'on
peut voir quels sont les derrière les
les modes de financement possibles mais
ça aussi je crois que c'était ça faisait
partie de des questions que vous nous
aviez envoyé par
avance sur les taux d'encadrement c'est
c'est vraiment un critère majeur de la
qualité de l'accueil et de ce point de
vuelà on s'est on s'est rapproché des
travaux des 1000 premiers jours puisque
le rapport de la commission des 1000
premiers jours préconisait de respecter
le ratio d'un adulte pour 5 enfants et
la littérature scientifique établit un
minim un optimum de 1 pour 3 pour les
enfants de moins de 2 ans et un adulte
pour 4 ou un adulte pour 5 5 enfants
pour les plus de 2
ans or
aujourd'hui donc on est sur un pour 5
enfants qui ne marchent pas et un adulte
pour H enfants qui
marchent alors la réforme Norma a
introduit la possibilité d'opter donc
c'est une possibilité pour un taux
d'encadrement unique d'un professionnel
pour 6
enfants alors la question de
l'encadrement de même que la question de
des conditions de travail du personnel
euh se sont avéré être extrêmement
importante
euh en ce qui concerne le la qualité euh
et les et l'attractivité du du secteur
et derrière les créations de place
puisque un des soucis que l'on percevait
auprès de beaucoup d'interlocuteurs
c'était oui mais il faut absolument
pouvoir continuer à créer des places ou
en tout cas ne pas ne pas en supprimer
et la question du du taux d'encadrement
était cruciale sur ce sujet
maintenant les taux d'encadrement actuel
il faut voir qu'il ne permettent pas de
travailler dans de bonnes
conditions c'est ce qu'on a vu au fil de
nos visites et ce qui ressortait de nos
questionnaires parce que cette situation
entraîne une charge de travail très
importante donc qui génère de la fatigue
du surmenage et par conséquence par fois
de la maltraitance envers les enfants et
donc il en résulte pour ces
professionnels que nous avons rencontré
que nous avons vu parfois longuement
puisque lorsqu'on nous allions dans les
crèches nous on pouvait rester dans une
salle s'asseoir se faire oublier presque
mais en tout cas regardez comment ça se
passe et on éétait pas juste dans un
entretien
euh et là on voyait que donc le la
question de l'encadrement et des
conditions de travail est importante
parce que très très vite il peut y avoir
une perte de sens pour les
professionnels qui qui sentent qu'ils
sont dans l'impossibilité de faire
correctement leur travail de prendre en
charge les enfants dans dans de bonnes
conditions et pour un certain nombre de
ne pas poursuivre dans cette voie
professionnelle et c'est pour ça que les
les responsables de crèche sont
confrontés à des difficultés de
recrutement mais aussi un fort
turnover et je je me souviens très bien
d' des premières crèches que qu'on avait
visité ça m'avait
marqué quasiment je crois toutes les
jeunes filles qui étaient là devaient
avoir moins de 22 23 ans et il y avait
un un un taux de renouvellement très
important personne ne restait c'était
trop dur euh et donc les ratios
d'encadrement sont ins titre un élément
d'attractivité de fidélisation du
personnel et donc je crois que ça c'est
un élément clé c'est que si on veut
créer des places il faut qu'il y ait des
personnels derrière pour euh pour armer
ces ces crèches et à partir de là pour
avoir du personnel et bien il faut avoir
des conditions de travail correctes donc
c'est c'est un point vraiment essentiel
sur lequel on voulait attirer
l'attention sur le mod sur le la
question du des modes de financement
enfin on voit bien que si on aborde la
question du point de vue de la qualité
qui était au centre de la mission ou du
point de vue de la même de la quantité
c'estàd de la création de place on voit
bien que il ateur est bien placé pour le
savoir que de loin en loin on a du mal à
créer une dynamique de création de place
pour répondre au besoins des des
familles qui ont qui ont besoin de
solution pour leur enfant et donc
aujourd'hui on est la mission en tout
cas a fait le constat d'un d'un relatif
échec de de ces modes de financement
d'un côté la page qui est ce dispositif
dérogatoire qui a amené d'une part un
lien distendu entre la branche famille
entre les opérateurs qui sont amenés à
contrôler cette qualité et et les et les
les établissements
qui a aussi conduit à un certain nombre
de dispositifs dérogatoires qui
permettent par exemple à certaines
heures de la journée aux heures aux
heures de matinée de soir de n'avoir
qu'un seul professionnel pour accueillir
les enfants d' n'avoir pas un
responsable d'établissement mais en
avoir plusieurs sur plusieurs
établissements donc on a un problème
d'encadrement sur des professionnels en
plus qui sont comme l'a dit mon collègue
plus jeune donc qui ont besoin d'être
étayés pourtant donc on a mis en place
toute une série de de disposition
dérogatoire sur la page qui permet cette
dynamique d'ailleurs de de création de
place mais qui détériore l'activité et
qui peut être générateur d'autres
missions le diront mais de de d'ffets de
de marge de marge important parce
qu'évidemment la marche salariale est
moins importante et puis de l'autre côté
la la la PSU le mécanisme de PSU qui
parce qu'on a essayé justement d'avoir
ses objectifs de payer au plus juste des
familles et c'est tant mieux et
d'essayer d'être de de d'amener une plus
grande fréquentation des crèches et cant
mieux en fait ça n'a pas marché on voit
que le taux de fréquentation le taux de
remplissage des crèches n'a pas bougé du
passage du forfaitaire au taux horaire
en revanche ce que ça a produit euh
c'est que ça a mis les établissement en
plus grande difficulté parce qu'ils
avaient une pression extrêmement forte
pour être au rendez-vous de cette tau de
fréquentation pour obtenir les
financements ce qui induit d'une part un
stress au niveau des professionnels qui
sont aussi dans des logiques
administratives très fortes qui sont
loin éloigné du métier et donc les PRES
se disent ben moi je suis pas je me suis
pas engagé en la petite enfance pour
faire de la paperacee entre guillemets
si je suis un peu schématique mais je
suis là pour être auprès des parents et
des enfants et des parents et en plus je
suis dans un environnement où justement
il manque des professionnels donc je les
besoins métiers sont encore plus
importants et puis et puis par ailleurs
ça a amené ce qu'on a décrit dans dans
le rapport des des mécanismes de sur sur
compensation c'estd qu'on sait très bien
que si on veut un taux de remplissage
d'une crèche moyen on sait très bien que
en début de journée ou en fin de journée
là où les enfants arrivent et partent B
le le ce taux est plus faible et donc on
va
sur faire fréquenter la crèche aux
heures méridiennes de de la journée là
où en plus les enfants donc sont plus
nombreux et demandent le plus
d'attention puisque c'est l'heure des
repas qui sont un vrai sujet et et des
temps de sieste et s'adapter justement
au besoins de l'enfant c'estàd pas tout
le monde en même temps à la sieste mais
chacun va aussi au gré de de de de ses
besoins et donc on voit qu'on a
concentré on concentre quantitativement
les enfants sur des périodes de la
journée et dans les immersions on peut
on se met à la place des professionnels
c'est extrêmement dur on a concentré les
les enfants dans les moments où ils ont
le plus de besoin donc on marche un peu
un peu un peu sur la tête tant sur plan
quantitatif mais aussi qualitatif et
donc nous ce qu'on propose c'est d'une
part alors tout ça doit se faire
évidemment dans la durée en associant
l'ensemble des parties prenantes mais un
processus d'extinction de la page pour
basculer sur la PSU et quand on en
discute même avec les euh celles et ceux
vous les auditionnerez qui qui
aujourd'hui bénéficient de la page je
parle des des des des groupes de de
crèche notamment privé ils sont plutôt
favorables parce que ça leur donne plus
de stabilité de visibilité et puis sur
la PSU de sortir cette logique de de
taux horaire qui crée qui met en tout le
secteur en en tension et qui de toute
façon ne répond aux objectifs de qualité
ni de quantité parce que avant tout
objectif de quantité tant qu'on arrivera
pas collectivement à faire en sorte que
ce secteur soit de nouveau attractif et
que les professionnels y demeurent on
peut on nous ne parviendrons ni à
améliorer la qualité des établissements
ni à à permettre de créer des places
parce que pour avoir des places pour les
réarmer de d'un C nombre un certain
nombre de de professionnels et
qu'aujourd'hui la CAF la knaf a fait une
étude en en juillet 2022 disant qu'il y
avait 10000 professionnels tout toute
compétence confondu manquant pour faire
tourner les crèches les 480000 places
actuelles ça veut dire qu'il y a 10000
places de Ferm au jour jour
d'aujourd'hui et donc pour aboutir à
cette à ces enjeux de création de place
et d'amélioration de la qualité il faut
absolument rendre cette cette profession
à nouveau attractif fidéliser ceux qui y
sont et le mode de financement en fait
partie
merci beaucoup j'imagine que ça va
appeler de nombreuses questions de de de
mes collègues je vais donc passer la
parole aux représentants des groupes en
commençant par William Martinet pour la
France
insoumise merci monsieur le président
madame messieurs merci de votre présence
pour cette audition et merci pour la
qualité de votre travail merci pour ce
rapport de Ligas je crois qu'il a eu eu
un rôle important pour faire prendre
conscience des difficultés dans le
secteur de la petite enfance alors on
peut voir le verre à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein si on le voit à moitié vide
on peut se dire que les professionnels
du secteur leurs organisations
syndicales depuis des années et des
années pointaient les difficultés et
qu'elles n'était pas entendu si on voit
les choses positivement votre rapport
mes des MOS apportent la légitimité de
l'institution qui fait qu'on a réussi à
à percer le mur de l'indifférence et que
cette question des problématiques de la
petite enfance sont euh enfin devenu un
débat politique euh il faut dire aussi
que votre rapport euh a eu un rôle clé
dans l'existence de cette commission
d'enquête puisque je me permets de dire
euh en tant que député qui a déposé la
résolution visant à créer cette
commission d'enquête c'est à la suite de
votre rapport et surtout à la suite de
mon point de vue du manque de réponse
politique à votre rapport que je me suis
permis de demander cette commission
d'enquête et je suis très heureux
qu'elle puisse euh se réaliser
aujourd'hui alors euh mes questions mon
propos euh porteront sur le sujet précis
du du modèle économique des entreprises
de crèche qui était d'ailleurs
initialement le thème de cette demande
de commission
d'enquête vous le savez il y a 20 ans le
secteur de la petite enfance a été
ouvert aux acteurs privés lucratifs avec
un modèle économique qu'on peut juger
comme très avantageux voire même plus
avantageux que celui qui est à
destination des acteurs associatif et
public parce que je pense notamment à ce
crédit d'impôt famille assez mal nommé
parce que il bénéficie aux entreprises
qui achètent des berceaux pour leurs
salariés et qui a un coût très important
pour pour les pouvoirs publics le
résultat de ce modèle économique très
avantageux et bien sans surprise c'est
une privatisation du secteur de la
petite enfance qui se fait à la fois de
façon discrète mais éclair puisque ces
10 dernières années c'est un chiffre
qu'on connaît ces 10 dernières années 80
% des ouvertures de places en crèche
l'ont été par des acteurs privés
lucratifs quel est le bilan de cette
privatisation et bien je crois que votre
rapport
apporte des éléments chiffrés et des
éléments qu'on peut considérer comme
comme critique cette privatisation du
secteur elle coûte cher aux finances
publiques du fait du modèle économique
elle coûte cher aux parents je pense
notamment aux micro crèche et au prix
d'inscription que payent les parents qui
sont qui sont très élevés un modèle avec
comme résultat que les professionnels
ils sont moins bien payés qu'ailleurs
puisqu'on sait que les professionnels
travaillant dans les entreprises de
crèche ont des rémunérations en moyenne
plus basse que dans le secteur
associatif ou ou public et avec comme
résultat là je je reprends les termes de
votre rapport une recherche de
rentabilité qui dans certaines
situations peut poser un problème pour
la qualité de l'accueil des jeunes
enfants formuler autrement là je vais
prendre les mots des journalistes qui
ont enquêté sur le sujet et qui ont
publié des ouvrages à la rentrée
dernière ces journalistes parlent de
maltraitance économique dont sont
victime sont victimes les enfants donc
avec ce bilan sommes tout assez critiqu
on peut se poser la question de quel est
le le point positif de cette
privatisation du secteur alors sans
doute que pour les actionnaires de ces
entreprises de crèche il y a du bénéfice
il y a de la rentabilité il y a de
l'intérêt et là j'en arrive à ma
première question nous avons constaté et
vous l'avez constaté dans votre rapport
un mouvement de financiarisation du
secteur de la petite enfance et là aussi
j'essaie d'être précis he je je reprends
je reprends vos termes vous parlez de
l'entrée des fonds de capital
investissement dans l'actionnariat du
secteur qui doit susciter la vigilance
de l'État tant pour les risques de coû
fin que représente cette dynamique que
pour les exigences de rentabilité qui
peuvent lui être associé ma première
question qui qui est assez large
j'aimerais un peu plus votre point de
vue sur les conséquences de cette
financiarisation du secteur de la petite
enfance et les mesures politiques qui
devraient être prises pour y répondre
l'encadrer je je vous laisserai
développer votre point de vue ma
deuxième question qui est un peu plus
précise votre rapport parle de zone de
risque quant à l'utilisation de l'argent
public dans ces entreprises de là aussi
je je suis très précis he je cite le
rapport vous dites que il y a un risque
que la multiplication des sources de
financement public contribue davantage
au taux de marge des entreprises qu'à la
qualité de l'accueil des jeunes enfants
on est donc là sur des éléments qui sont
très critiques sur le le modèle
économique de ces de ces entreprises et
cette critique vous ne la faites pas à
la légère vous donnez des éléments très
précis on apprend par exemple que dans
les entreprises de crèche le coût de la
masse salariale par berceau a baissé de
2 % ces 10 dernières années alors que le
SMIC a augmenté alors que les prix ont
augmenté en général vous comparez très
intéressant avec l'associatif plus 11 %
sur la même période le public plus 18 %
alors là on a la preuve chiffrée de je
sais pas comment il faut le dire un plan
d'austérité dans la masse salariale des
entreprises de crèche qui sans doute
explique beaucoup de difficultés qui
sont rencontrées dans ces établissements
vous dites aussi et ça de quoi n nous
inquiéter vous parlez oui je je
j'approche de ma conclusion monsieur le
Président mais j'ai des questions je
crois intéressantes à poser au personnes
alle posez-les euh je vous vous signalis
dans les comptes de ces entreprises de
crèche une augmentation de 28 % des
dotations aux amortissements et vous
posez la question est-ce que l'argent
public ne contribuerait pas à constituer
le capital immobilier de ces entreprises
de crèche de même vous signalez dans les
comptes de ces entreprises une
augmentation de 51 % du compte autre
charge dont on sait que cela peut
correspondre aux frais qui sont remontés
au sièges des grands groupes et qui sont
finalement une perte de traçabilité de
l'argent de l'argent public donc encore
une fois vous posez des des questions
assez inquiétantes sur où va l'argent
public et pour être très précis sur
cette question vous recommandez une
mission de contrôle ciblée sur un ou
plusieurs groupes qui doit conduire à
une étude plus précise des comptes donc
du coup ma question est-ce que à votre
connaissance cette étude ciblée sur
certains grands groupes est-ce qu'elle a
été menée est-ce qu'elle est en cours et
si jamais ce n'est pas le cas et bien
écoutez vous avez la chance d'avoir une
commission d'enquête parlementaire
devant vous nous à avec plaisir nous
mènerons cette étude je veux bien que
vous nous aidiez en nous disant quelle
question poser quel document solliciter
parce que évidemment je ne doute pas
qu'on rencontrera bientôt les les grands
roues et ma dernière question j'arrête
vraiment là-dessus sur le sujet de la
rentabilité des entreprises de crèche
parce que c'est un sujet un peu de de
débat de pingpong même depuis quelques
années entre l'administration et le
lobby des crèches privées lias une
première fois à parler de jusqu'à 30 %
de niveau de rentabilité la Fédération
française des entreprises de crèche a
répondu en disant non pas du tout on est
à 3 % en moyenne et alors là aussi je
lis votre rapport ce sera ma dernière
citation mais cet excellent rapport
mérite d'être cité vous nous dites que
finalement le cabinet de conseil qui a
produit le chiffre de la Fédération
française des entreprises de crèche
n'engage pas sa responsabilité sur ces
estimations et vous nous dites même que
quand Ligas confronte les chiffres de la
Fédération française des entreprises de
crèche avec la source des données
comptables vous trouvez un écart vous
trouvez une différence donc là j'ai
l'impression que excusez-mo - moi de le
dire vous accusez la Fédération
française des entreprises de crèche de
ne pas avoir donné de vrais chiffres sur
leur niveau de rentabilité alors là
j'arrête vraiment là-dessus c'est ma
dernière question comment peut-on faire
pour avoir le vrai niveau de rentabilité
de ces groupes nous sommes membres de la
représentation nationale ces groupes
reçoivent de l'argent public nous
voulons savoir quelle est leur
rentabilité si vous voulez bien nous
dire quelle question leur poser quel
document solliciter je vous remercie
merci mon chers collègue la parole est à
Alexandra Martin pour le groupe les
républicain merci merci monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup madame
messieurs moi je je voudrais revenir
vous avez répondu à de très nombreuses
questions déjà je voudrais revenir sur
la le lien entre la parentalité et les
crèches qui est au confin de la sécurité
affective de la sécurité tout court des
enfants mais mais aussi la parentalité
qui est un sujet aujourd'hui qui est au
cœur de de nombreux sujets et fléau
sociétaux euh tous les acteurs en fait
de de la protection de l'enfance y
compris les crèches
doivent de mon point de vue être en
mesure d'accompagner cette parentalité
mais bien sûr cette relation doit être
réciproque
euh moi j'ai la conviction qu'il faut
effectivement associer davantage les
parents vous l'avez dit vous-même vous
esquissz d'ailleurs une piste vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous appelez à
mettre un terme à ce que vous appelez la
conception du parent comme un client
d'un simple mode de garde euh vous vous
connuser au contraire d'encourager les
crèches à mettre en place des projets
spécifiques pédagogiques ludiques
attribuant un rôle plus actif aux
parents dans son fonctionnement et
soutenant la parentalité vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de conseil des parents
quen est-il de la faisabilité d'une
telle mesure connaissez-vous des crèches
qui ont eu recours à à ce genre de de
proposition et qu'elle a été le résultat
de même investir les parents je le
disais au début au sein des CR n'est-ce
pas là la garantie aussi de contrôle et
de surveillance face aux dérives
éventuelles
merci merci ma cher collègue la parole
est au groupe démocrate avec Anne
bergant merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et et Messieurs les les
rapporteurs donc évidemment je m'associe
à mes collègues pour vous féliciter pour
le travail que vous avez effectué qui
constitue clairement une base
extrêmement solide pour notre mission
d'enquête alors je euh je je sais que
vous avez déjà répondu parfois en partie
à mes questions mais j'auraiis quand
même quelques demandes de précision sur
trois points euh qualité de l'accueil
bon un travail vous l'avez rappelé a
déjà été fait et notamment avec la
charte nationale d'accueil du du jeune
enfant avec des objectifs assez simples
clairs euh aussi de bienveillance
respect du rythme de l'enfant euh aller
à l'extérieur motricité libre enfin vous
avez rappelé tout ceci et dans le même
temps donc il y a un affichage
évidemment de cette charte dans tous les
établissements euh mais une
appropriation on va dire diverse euh de
cette charte par les par les
professionnels et dans le même temps euh
on note quand même une obligation faite
aux établ
d'avoir également des projets
d'établissement qui sont aussi des
obligations assez chronophages assez
formelles et stéréotypées vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs dans votre rapport alors
je me demande très naïvement est-ce
qu'on se disperse pas trop et est-ce
qu'il ne serait pas utile de de
peut-être se concentrer sur l'essentiel
et notamment peut-être sur cette charte
pour aller vers une qualité d'accueil je
dirais plus plus homogène sur le terrain
deuxièmement le contrôle ça vous l'avez
déjà évoqué plusieurs acteurs œuvr dans
le contrôle chacun dans ses domaines de
compétences PMI CAF mais vous avez
évoqué dans votre recommandation numéro
39 quelque chose de très intéressant et
de la mise en place d'une évaluation
croisée par les paires et j'aimerais que
vous reveniez sur cette recommandation
je ne sais pas si elle a fait l'objet
d'observation sur le terrain mais je
trouve que c'est extrêmement intéressant
et
troisièmement votre recommand tion
numéro 37 de confier la compétence
relative à l'ouverture l'extension mais
aussi alors c'est pas la 37 peut-être la
38 sur la fermeture en fait des des
établissements donner donc pouvoir au
président du conseil départemental
pourriez-vous revenir sur l'intérêt que
représenterait pour vous la gestion de
ces compétences par le Conseil
départemental et et dernier point
parisque que c'était une question un peu
en de temps mais là je je je c'était pas
du tout l'objet de votre rapport donc je
ne sais pas si vous pourrez
apporter une réponse et je comprendrai
très bien si c'était pas le cas moi je
mets en lien aussi avec le PJL plein
emploi qui a été voté au mois de de
septembre et qui donne notamment qui
propose l'organisation de la gouvernance
en matière d'accueil du jeune enfant aux
communes est-ce que vous avez un avis
sur ce dernier point
merci merci ma chers collègues je vous
propose de d'enchaîner sur les
interventions individuelles des députés
dans l'ordre d'in tionut pas par les
questiont mais comme certains groupes
ont préférit ne pas être dans
l'intervention de groupe mais dans les
questions individuelles vu le le nombre
il me semble on combien de question
avant ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai j'ai
que quatre inscrits donc je vous propose
monsieur Martinet d'ailleurs de de
commencer puisque c'est le premier
inscrit sauf
si d'accord ben je vous propose de de
prendre Béatrice rouleau pour le
rassembl national
oui je voulais vous remercier et je
voulais vous remercier donc de votre
travail d'inspection en général du
rapport que je vous avez fait pour ma
part j'ai commencé à le lire je n'ai pas
terminé je vais le lire avec grande
attention euh bientôt et les premières
pages ont été
euh significatives et surtout m'ont euh
beaucoup intéressé beaucoup touché alors
j'ai plusieurs questions
à travers ce que j'ai l ce que vous avez
dit ce matin je voudrais d'abord poser
des questions sur la
charte donc cette charte elle n'a pas de
valeur contraignante pensez-vous qu'une
valeur contraignante avec un système
qu'il faut imaginer pourquoi pas même
des sanctions civiles ou pénales il
faudrait réfléchir à cela puissent être
un levier pour appliquer les 10
principes de cette charte qui pourrait
peut-être être résumé être concentré sur
l'essentiel comme vient de le dire ma
collègue mais en tout cas pour un
respect de la charte parce
qu'effectivement certaines remarques
certaines expériences sont choquantes
moi qu'est-ce qui m'a choqué
euh ça ne me vient pas tout de suite
mais qu'est-ce qui m'a choqué enfin
plusieurs choses d'ailleurs qu'on
laissait évidemment pleurer les enfants
ce que vous venez de dire qu'on les
prenait pas dans les bras et donc je
pense qu'il faut que cette charte est
une valeur contraignante et soit sortie
de sanctions dirigé à contre sans doute
du responsable parce que je pense que
c'est au niveau de la direction surtout
qu'il faut agir oui ce qui m'a choqué
c'est par exemple une jeune femme qui
s'est qui s'est meuvé du fait
que que les enfants on les laissait
pleurer ou qu'on les attachait on lui a
dit mais tu n'es pas obligé de faire
pareil donc il y a quand même là une
responsabilité de le du de la direction
et je pense qu'il faut travailler sur le
fait de
responsabiliser les les
les directeurs et voir sanctionner euh
donc ça c'était sur la charte
ensuite j'en ai une petite d'ailleurs
que j'aurais dû poser en introduction on
on on sait bien qu'on est sur une
enquête sur les PR crèches privées mais
là dans le rapport je suis désolée de
vous poser la question mais est-ce que
ça concerne toutes les crèches à mon
avis puisque ce n'a pas été précisé là
c'est toute crèche confondue hein que ce
soit le modèle associatif privatif
public bon là vous m'avez répondu merci
beaucoup euh je je vais pas non plus
trop monopoliser mais j'ai des milieux
de questions alors sur les conditions de
recrutement parce que ce qui était très
intéressant c'est que vous avez dit
souvent que le personnel est un
personnel parfois fragilisé en tout cas
souvent très jeune faut-il revoir les
les conditions faut-il se poser la
question sur une limite d'âge ou au
moins euh un examen d'entretien
particulier avec la personne pour
pouvoir déceler d'éventuelles fragilités
faut-il voilà faut-il
assortir le recrutement de certaines
conditions et puis je vais m'arrêter là
j'en ai plein mais je vais laisser la
parole à mes collègues merci beaucoup
William
Martinet il faut éteindre votre micro
pardon oui monsieur le Président
permettez-moi de de redire au micro que
l'organisation des débats me semble pas
satisfaisante quand il y a trop de
questions successives il est compliqué
pour les personnes auditionnées de
pouvoir répondre correctement moi je
j'aborde ces audition de la façon la
plus constructive possible mais on va
pas faire comme si il y avait pas de
contexte sur cette commission d'enquête
et on va pas faire comme si l'auteur que
je suis de la demande de commission
d'enquête a été écarté des postes à
responsabilité dans cette commission
monsieur
présidentous donous j'ai bloqué aucun
temps je vous dis justement j'ai pas
j'ai voulu que vous puissiez poser
toutes vos questions d'ailleurs je vous
ai laissé 7 minutes d'habitude la
pratique en commission et sur des
interventions plus courtes justement
pour vous laisser le temps posez vos
questions n'hésitez pas allez-y mais je
j'aimerais que les les personnes
auditionné et aussi l'occasion d' d'y
répondre et donc je je vais poser mes
questions je m'excuse encore une fois de
de la liste qui va commencer à être un
peu un peu longue et en plus comme ce
sont des des questions précises j'espère
qu'elles pourront amener à des à des
réponses précises euh question sur les
délégations de services publics aux
acteurs privé lucratif vous évoquez
cette question dans votre rapport et
notamment un phénomène c'est délégations
de servic public qui participe à tirer
vers le bas le coût à la place alors ce
qui peut-être du point de vue de la
collectivité d'un point de vue
gestionnaire est intéressant mais pour
l'intérêt des enfants évidemment c'est
plus c'est plus problématique vous citez
euh des délégations de service public
avec des prix qui descendent jusqu'à
3000 € à la place que vous jugez
incompatible avec la qualité de
l'accueil des jeunes enfants vous
évoquez dans votre rapport je crois un
minimum de 5000 € par place pour la
qualité alors c'est intéressant parce
que en commission des affaires sociales
nous avions un collègue euh monsieur
monsieur Juvin maire de la Garen colombe
qui expliquait que lui dans sa ville à
4000 € la place ça se passait très bien
est-ce que vous pensez que à 4000 € la
place on peut vraiment accueillir les
enfants dans de bonnes conditions c'est
ce que semble dire monsieur Juvin en
parlant de des crèches en DSP à la ger
colombe deuxème et dernière question
pour rassurer monsieur le le Président
je vais évoquer une une situation
particulière qui qui a été assez
dramatique mais j'ai rencontré les
parents de l'enfant concerné et le sujet
a été évoqué dans la presse alors je me
permets de l'évoquer dans cette audition
à Montrouge il y a quelques semaines un
jeune enfant a eu le doigt sexné dans la
roue d'un chariot ça s'est déroulé dans
une crèche du groupe La Maison Bleue
semble-t-il il y avait un problème sur
le respect des normes et notamment du
chariot utilisé c'était un exercice
d'évacuation des enfants c'est très bien
de faire un exercice d'évacuation mais
il faut le faire avec du matériel adapté
pour pas que ça se traduise par
l'événement dramatique qui a eu euh qui
a eu eu lieu alors première chose
j'entends beaucoup et c'est sans doute
vrai que la PMI doit pas se concentrer
seulement sur le contrôle bâtimentaire
bon benah là il y avait peut-être un
sujet don il fallait contrôler les
chariots pour que cet événement ne
n'arrive pas et le et là vraiment ma ma
question euh si j'ai bien compris la
réaction du groupe La Maison Bleue ce
chariot était utilisé dans plusieurs
crèches et ils ont demandé à au moins 21
crèches de retirer ce chariot qui est
manifestement dangereux pour les enfants
là ça pose une question de contrôle quel
moyen a-t-on pour que au-delà de
montrrouge au-delà des hautes scènes on
s'assure que dans tout le pays il y ait
pas d'autres crèches de la maison bleue
qui fonctionnent avec ce matériel eu
voilà donc là aujourd'hui quel
concrètement qu'est-ce qui devrait être
fait pour que euh le contrôle soit
effectué et quel évolution réglementaire
législative doit être faite pour que ce
type d'incident dramatique entraîne un
contrôle plus large à l'échelle de
l'ensemble du territoire et pour
évidemment éviter que ces drames se se
reproduisent merci merci la parole est à
Philippe Loo oui rembl monsieur
président merci Monsieur alors dans
l'esprit comment peut-on améliorer le
système trois sujets rapides premier que
vous avez déjà évoqué c'est la PSU
c'est-à-dire en effet on a ça introduit
de la complexité et dans la gestion et
dans le fonctionnement des structures
bon j'ais posé une question est-ce qu'il
faut garder le système je crois que vous
avez déjà quasiment répondu PSU horaire
c'est un premier point deuxième point
bon si les collectés sont tournés vers
le privé c'est qu'elle y avait un
intérêt avec sans doute une meilleure
optimisation du privé maintenant il y a
une limite en est effet il peut y avoir
des dérives mon collègue vient juste de
l'aborder en effet est-ce que les règles
de la DSP sont adaptées au système
c'est-à-dire il y a une sorte de course
à l'échalotte pour tirer les prix vers
le bas et on va vers le on sait que de
plus en plus on donne au moins 10 ans
pas forcément mieux 10 ans et est-ce que
il y a des moyens visàis de la commande
publique de redresser tout ça peut-être
accompagner mais je crois que c'est pour
moi c'est un point majeur ce ce ce tirer
le prix vers le bas et un moment on est
fait à 3000 € on peut plus y arriver
dernier point vous avez évoqué le
renforcement de l'encadrement très bien
mais est-ce que le mieux est PASM du
bien c'est-à-dire une crèche ça coûte
comme dirait l'autre un pogon de dingue
à faire fonctionner si on y rajoute
encore de l'encadrement il y a une
collectivités qui vont plus pouvoir y
arriver c'est-à-dire si elles doivent
encore augmenter la masse salariale dans
les secteur à un moment a puis arriver
on risque d'avoir l'effet inverse
c'estàdire on risque d'avoir finalement
un moindre nombre de places est-ce que
c'est pas le risque est-ce qu'il y a pas
justement cet équilibre actuel ne
faut-il pas le garder même si on peut se
dire que ça serait mieux forcment avec
plus d'encadrement parce un risque
d'avoir finalement moins de placees en
tout cas plus de création voilà je vous
remercie merci dernière dernier
intervenant Thierry frappé pour le
rassemble
national merci monsieur le Président
merci à vous trois qui avez fait ce
rapport donc au nom de de Ligas et qui
nous a mis en lumière beaucoup de choses
de ce rapport j'ai d'abord retenu un
constat qui concerne la disparité des
lieux disparité qui est j'ai cru
comprendre très grande selon les
départements et selon les établissements
euh alors disparité également des prises
en charge par rapport au nombre
d'enfants pris en charge vous dites
l'optimal ce serait 6 euh alors qu'on
est à 5 ou
dans les meilleures conditions
aujourd'hui selon que les enfants
marchent ou ne marchent pas est-ce que
ça ne jouera pas sur le fonctionnement
des crèches d'arriver à ce chiffre qui
est souhaitable je suis est tout à fait
d'accord mais quells seront quelle sera
son incidence sur la
pratique pour cela il y a deux
préconisations que j'ai retenu alors la
mise en conformité de ce nombre moyen
d'enfants effectivement qui est
souhaitable et la deuxième chose c'est
une évaluation des exigences applicables
pour les locaux et les équipements que
vous souhaitez de façon optimale au 2e
semestre 2024 c'est-à-dire demain euh ça
va aller très vite
ces visites de contrôle
euh vont être faites semestriel en code
manquement par qui les parents le
département l'État et pourquoi pas la
Haute Autorité de santé qui pourrait
faire des
accréditation aux crèches à revoir
régulièrement comme c'est fait dans les
cliniques ou dans les cabinets médicaux
ou autres euh la PMI la caisse
d'allocation familiale sont bien sûr
concerné mais plus dans le domaine
immobilier voilà c'était ma ma question
donc qui préconisez-vous au niveau de
ces visites et est-ce que il faut faire
une
accréditation
merci merci euh donc voilà vous avez eu
six intervenants dont un deux fois euh
ce qui est moins que le nombre de
groupes de la maison
euh vous avez vous vous allez donc
pouvoir répondre sur l'ensemble des
questions pour les besoins aussi des de
de du compte-rendu je pense qu'il est
important aussi parce que ça parfois ça
a été le cas par exemple pour la
rapporteur vous avez pas répondu à
toutes les questions préciseer quand
vous avez pas les éléments ou que
c'était pas dans le périmètre mais c'est
important pour nous que c'est pas une
non réponse parce que vous ne voulez pas
répondre mais que vous avez pas
forcément les éléments j'en profite
puisque vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
les besoins des enfants nous
auditionnerons dès la semaine
prochaine madame Casso Vicarini membre
de la commission sur les 1000 premiers
jours et
notre collègue William Martinet a
mentionné les les journal les auteurs
des des ouvrages parus à l'automne
dernier que nous recevrons et également
le programme est encore en train d'être
calé mais je vous invite à à vraiment
réserver le milieu de semaine prochaine
pour pour ces audition sans plus
attendre la parole est à vous trois pour
répondre à l'ensemble de ces
questions merci monsieur le Président
alors pour répondre à aux questions qui
relèvent plus pertment des modèles
économiques euh des crèches des crèches
privées en fait euh comme vous l'avez
indiqué le rapport se contente de tracer
des points de de soupçon d'indice qui
nous font dire que il y a effectivement
un modèle économique qui qui est lié
notamment au modèle des microcrèche vous
vous avez relevé la question par exemple
euh de l'évolution de la masse salariale
elle est liée peut-être à des des sujets
de rémunération mais aussi lié au modèle
dérogatoire de l'encadrement dans les
microocesches puisque comme je l'ai dit
à certaines heures de la journée on peut
être sur un seul professionnel là où ce
n'est pas possible dans d'autres
établissements donc il faut c'est pour
ça que nous on s'est contenté de poser
des questions et de se dire finalement
quand on voit vous l'avez souligné des
des des comment des comportements très
agressifs dans les DSP avec des des prix
cassés au berceau en voyant un certain
nombre de d'indice d'indice comptable on
peut se dire qu'il y a effectivement des
questions à se poser sur ce modèle
économique précis d'ailleurs c'est pour
cela qu'une mission de IGAS et de l'IGF
de l'Inspection générale des finances
est en cours sur le modèle spécifique
des micrococrèches pour comprendre tous
les les ressorts de ce modèle que nous
n'avons pas pu aborder au-delà de de ce
que nous avons pu pointer dans le dans
le dans le rapport ceci étant dit il est
important aussi même s'il a un sujet
microcrèche et et crèche privé d'abord
de se dire ce n'est pas que les grands
groupes nous avons aussi rencontré des
entreprises de petite taille personnel
qui ont développé des micro crèches des
gens qui ne sont pas du tout de la
profession qui ont qui se sont saisis de
ce dispositif de la page pour investir
une nouvelle activité professionnelle
qui génère les mêmes les mêmes effets
donc regarder les grands groupes c'est
bien mais aussi parce que là on change
d'échelle évidemment mais regardeer
aussi ce que ça produit comme comme
effet aussi par rapport à des petits
établissements qui blissent au même au
même mécanisme économique et qui peuvent
produire aussi des effets des effets
voilà qui pour qui pose des questions en
terme de qualité on l' nous on l'a pu le
constater par des des personnes qui sont
pas forcément formées au besoins de de
la petite enfance plus plus largement je
pense que on essaie de le marteler et
pardon si nous sommes redondant mais le
problème est vraiment systémique et que
on peut focaliser ou se centrer sur un
dispositif de crèche de de micro crèche
de crèches privées des grands groupes
mais résoudre la problématique de la
petite enfance et de l'accueil de la
petite enfance à cette problématique là
c'est peut-être important mais ça serait
réducteur et que si parce que les
opérateurs ils vous le diront quand vous
les auditionnerez ils sont confrontés
aux mêmes difficultés de recrutement et
c'est le cœur du réacteur le cœur du
réacteur c'est c'est d'abord un métier
d'homme et de femme et et donc comment
on rend ce métier attractif pour vous
donner un exemple pour pouvoir répondre
aux besoins de recrutement pour faire
fonctionner les crèches de manière
normale aujourd'hui c'estd les 10000
professionnels qui son qui ont été
estimés avec tout toutes les réserves
posses par la CAF comme manquant
aujourd'hui pour faire tourner les
crèches il faut une année pleine de
formation donc ça veut dire que
indépendamment des départs en retraite
des départs naturels et cetera il
faudrait que l'appareil de formation
soit complètement mobilisé pour
remplacer pour permettre de de palier au
au manque de personnel aujourd'hui dans
les crèches un an de formation ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut un effort
extrêmement important de formation par
ailleurs toujours dans cet esprit
systémique une des recommandations du
rapport c'est aussi et ça ça répond en
creux à à vos questions sur le modèle
économique et sur les concurrences
privées associatif et public c'est une
des recommandations c'est de rendre le
schéma départemental
euh dédié à la petite enfance o
opposable c'est-à-dire de faire en sorte
que on régule l'offre aujourd'hui on l'a
vu nous euh au gré des de nos visites
hein on a vu des des structures
associatives ou des structures public
mise en difficulté par l'arrivée de
crèches privées qui arrivent sur
d'autres modèles mais qui viennent
siiponner permet-toi l'expression une
partie de la clientèle de des parents
qui étaient dans ces dans ces crèches et
donc on a vu on a pour être très clair
on était dans la banlieue de d'Amien une
crèche associative de qualité on se
disait enfin parce qu'on a vu quand même
des choses un peu compliquées là on se
dit voilà tout tout se passe bien et
puis finalement à la fin de la la
rencontre la directrice de la crèche je
dit bah écoutez je vous quitte parce que
j'ai une réunion avec la CAF qui va
essayer de voir comment je vais
consolider mon modèle parce qu'on a eu
l'implantation de crèchees de
microocèchees un peu partout sur le
territoire lié notamment à l'arrivée
d'entreprise de zon d'activité et que ça
a déstabilisé complètement nos nos notre
structure et donc on a un problème de
fréquentation donc c'est vraiment une
approche systémique qu' est qu' est
nécessaire d'avoir parce que on passera
à côté d'un certain nombre de sujets et
notamment désolé d'incister sur l'aspect
vraiment comment sur l'aspect formation
recrutement tant qu'on redonnera pas
envie de s'engager dans ces profession
tant qu'on fera pas attention comme vous
l'avez souigné madame au niveau aussi de
formation de ces de ces professionnels
on ne parviendra ni à renforcer la
qualité ni à être au rendez-vous des des
besoins de de création de
place donc il y a une mission sur qui
est en cours sur les microcèche et par
ailleurs suite à l'affaire notamment
Orpa vous savez qu'il y a un nombre de
dispositions réglementaires et
législatives qui sont en train d'évoluer
pour permettre au corps d'inspection que
nous sommes de pouvoir aller regarder
les effets de consolidation avec les
fris de sièges là ça passe largement
nous notre périmètre c'est
l'établissement c'est pas c'est pas le
siège qui dépasse qui dépasse notre
périmètre de compétence au-delà des
compétences métiers des compétences tout
courts légales et donc c'est aussi ces
évolutions réglementaires qui nous
permettent d'appréhender les mécanismes
de frais de siège d'optimisation ou
fiscale ou ou financière qui peuvent
avoir lieu sur ce type d'établissement
là il y a une mission qui va être lancé
oui
peut-être je
oui donc une une mission en effet doit
doit démarrer sur un groupe de crèche
c'est ça donc ensuite pour pour répondre
sur la question de de parentalité vous
nous aviez interpellé sur cette question
je pense que c'est vraiment essentiel et
on a bien vu euh qu'il y a eu en fait
une évolution dans les années 80 c'est
vrai que il y avait beaucoup de crèche
parentales il y en a encore mais souvent
il y en a qui fonctionnent encore comme
au départ avec des parents engagés dans
la crèche parfois c'est simplement des
parents qui qui sont dans le conseil
d'administration on va dire voilà mais
en effet la place des parents est
essentielle de leur redonner cette place
qu'ils a qu'il qu'ils se sentent partie
prenante de de quel que soit le type de
crèche de pouvoir avoir une place et et
et et avoir justement des des des
éléments de repérage comme on a dit tout
à l'heure l'UR pour être proactif et
travailler avec les les les personnes et
c'est vrai que dans les recommandations
que l'on a fait par exemple d'avoir pour
les microocèches par exemple où il est
autorisé de n'avoir qu'une personne le
matin et le soir jusqu'à ce qu' tant
tant qu'il y a pas plus de trois enfants
euh la recommandation elle était sur la
sécurité c'est une chose mais aussi sur
la parentalité parce que c'est bien
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il y avait une
zone de risque vous avez des enfants un
parent arrive on lui parle du coup on
regarde plus les autres comme on est
seul en plus voilà donc là il y a aussi
ça va permettre d'être à deux c'est
aussi d'être beaucoup plus présent
auprès des parents et véritablement avec
eux et
travailler enfin voilà de pouvoir
construire avec eux et puis c'est vrai
que c'est ce qui nous a été dit que
c'est c'est plus que les instances c'est
la présence le partage qui est important
avec les les parents donc en terme de
qualité aussi les les questions qui nous
ont été posées sur la la charte la
charte en fait elle elle s'impose
actuellement elle est bien dans les
textes donc elle est réglementaire donc
déjà on peut y travailler il y a un
groupe de travail actuellement au niveau
du ministère qui travaille au
référentiel pour les professionnels et
qui part de la Charte il s'agissait pas
de reux donc c'est c'est sylvien
jampinot la le Haut Conseil la famille
qui avait travaillé sur cette question
il faut partir de ça et qui est inscrit
dans les dans dans le marbre donc en
effet en partant de cette charte on a à
travailler une meilleure communication
aux parents et donc que ce soit quelque
chose qui soit plus que les 10 principes
bien bien habités bien partagés et puis
pour les d'avoir un référentiel de
qualité et un référentiel pour le
contrôle que tout ça soit dans la même
logique et donc tout ça est en train de
se travailler actuellement c'était
c'était dans nos recommandations aussi
he de pouvoir s'appuyer sur ces
questions pour construire les outils euh
c'est vrai qu'on avait pensé à la Haute
Autorité de santé mais il se trouve que
la Haute Autorité de santé n'est pas
habilité aujourd'hui à travailler sur
ces sur le domaine auquel appartient les
crèches c'est des tout simplement par
rapport au code de l'action sociale et
des familles il y a plusieurs livrets et
ils sont autorisés sur sur les les
établissements sociaux médicos-soaux
mais là on est pas dans les
établissements sociaux et médicossociaux
ça n'est pas voilà c'est en terme de
réglementation hein dans l'absolu c'est
voilà mais en tout cas voilà c'est pas
le même livre du code de l'action
sociale et des familles donc on a pour
autant demandé à ce que ça bouge mais
voilà il faut que ça ça prend du temps
donc il est ont déjà démarré avec la
avec des
référentiels de qualité et des guides de
contrôle qui partent de la même base
voilà voilà les les éléments donc la
charte est donc déjà contraignante et il
faut la faire vivre dans ce sens-là nous
sommes tout à fait d'accord d'accord
donc pour ce qui est de l'évaluation
croisée par les pairres c'est quelque
chose que l'on a repris en effet et qui
se fait et c'est vraiment très
intéressant et là dans l'absolu c'est si
c'était aussi justement entre
différentes différents statuts de crèche
donc bon pour le moment on l'a vu se
mettre en place dans des communes et
c'était des grosses agglomérations où il
y avait vraiment ce
travail de d'évaluation croisée
c'est-à-dire il y a quelqu'un là c'était
de la commune qui est en fait quelque
part un référent qualité sur l'ensemble
du territoire là qui va aller avec un
directeur de crèche dans une autre
crèche et donc c'est une évaluation par
les Pères comme l'on dit et c'est vrai
que c'est très efficace et l'idéal
serait que on casse les les les
barrières aussi entre les types de
crèche là par exemple c'était contre du
du public parce que c'était piloté par
la commune et l'ensemble de ces de ces
crèches mais mais il y a des repr
présentation sur les uns et les autres
et ce serait très intéressant de se
nourrir des des des des de la capacité
d'évaluation des uns et des autres et de
construire ensemble et donc là vous donc
vous verrez dans le rapport on a cité un
certain nombre de de communes de de
c'est plutôt des métropoles même
certains qui qui ont développé ça et
c'est vraiment merci d'avoir repérer
cette question parce qu'elle est elle
est très porteuse de de de travail et
c'est pour pour ça que aussi la la
question de la qualité
elle peut elle se trouve partout et et
elle peut aussi l'inverse les questions
de non qualité se trouve aussi partout
donc n'ayons pas de représentation a
priori de tel ou tel secteur après il y
a des éléments qui ne doivent pas passer
c'est-à-dire en terme de surface par
rapport au nombre d'enfants accueillis
on a vu les microocèche par exemple qui
était pensé pour u enfants au départ
puis la réglementation est passée à 10
puis on est pass passé à 12 et
maintenant c'est 12 avec 115 % de
possibilité donc parfois 15 donc si on
est dans 50 m² vous voyez on aura beau
dire que on part sur des petits groupes
le petit groupe il est devenu grand et
donc la question de de vraiment prendre
la la la globalité de la situation pas
s'arrêter seulement à à une présentation
générale prendre l'ensemble de des
éléments voilà je sais pas si j'ai je
pense avoir pris toutes les questions
qualité que
vous pour continuer sur il y avait une
question sur le les compétences du
président du conseil départemental
notamment pour la
fermeture bien tout simplement jusqu'à
présent ce que nous avions constaté
c'est que la décision d'ouverture de
création d'une structure était du
ressort des collectivités
territoriales or la décision de
fermeture était du ressort des service
de l'État c'était le préfet donc c'était
assez peu cohérent et donc c'est pour ça
que dans un souci de simplification et
de
cohérence après d'ailleurs avoir
consulté l'ADF euh nous avons proposé
cette mesure parce que finalement on l'a
vu dans les dans la situation de de Lyon
notamment les services de l'État qui qui
n'interviennent pas au quotidien
dans dans la vie des crèches puisque ils
sont pas en CH du contrôle ils sont pas
en charge de l'autorisation d'ouverture
se
retrouver à devoir décider d'une
fermeture donc ce qui ce qui entraînait
une lourdeur puisque il fallait saisir
un acteur en plus donc voilà ça ça nous
paraissait pas très cohérent il y avait
une autre question aussi sur le
renforcement du taux d'encadrement
est-ce que c'était est-ce que c'est
faisable ou pas alors pour nous il
s'agit pas forcément de de renforcer
mais plutôt par parfois de ne serait-ce
que de revenir à ce qui pouvait se faire
auparavant parce que vous avez dû le
voir en annexe 1 on a mis un tableau
comparatif qui permet sur quelques
points notamment taux
d'encadrement qualification des
personnels qui permet de voir
l'évolution de la réglementation au fil
des années et donc ça répond aussi à une
de vos questions sur ce qu' apporté
Norma ou pas et on voit que et bien que
ce soit sur l'auto d'encadrement ou sur
le niveau de qualification requis euh
des personnels présents dans la crèche
petit à petit on a assoupli les les
exigences et c'est ce qui fait que au
bout du compte on peut arriver à avoir
des structures dans lesquelles et bien
en optimisant au maximum on va
avoir assez peu de professionnels par
rapport à ce qu'il faudrait et puis très
peu de personnel avec personnel en tout
cas avec une formation supérieure au cap
ou quand il y en a un bah c'est c'est le
responsable de la crèche or
malheureusement comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui le responsable est
plus en charge de tâche administratif
parce qu'il doit remplir du fait du mode
de financement euh il faut faut remplir
faut remplir les heures et donc il est
plus souvent au téléphone à appeler des
parents pour voir s'il pourrait pas
mettre leur enfant pendant les heures
disponibles au lieu d'assurer
l'encadrement et d'être avec ses équipes
voilà
une question de de la rapporteur parce
que à une des questions de nos collègues
sur la DSP il semble pas vous a répondu
donc très
brièvement sur la délégation de service
public est-ce que il vous considère vous
considérez que c'est le montage en tant
que tel qui est problématique ou est-ce
que la question de des modalités de
passation de la délégation de service
public qui en particulier des critères
et de la pondération des critères euh
n'est pas plutôt structurante et si vous
constatez euh que beaucoup de communes
euh donnent au critèr prix euh une place
particulièrement importante est-ce que
euh finalement on doit s'interroger sur
le fait de savoir si c'est bien euh à
l'échelon com communal qu'il convient de
confier
euh cette mission et pas plutôt par
exemple à des départements qui ont euh
la PMI et qui ont donc euh une approche
qualitative de la prise en charge des
enfants en crèche qui est euh plus euh
prégnante si vousouz
oui euh sur la DSP effectivement c'est
la en fait qui qui veut peu c'est-à-dire
que si une commune et on l'a vu dans
certaines communes mettent mais la
qualité euh et que la qualité ça a
forcément un prix parce que ça va être
c'est plus de temps de professionnel
avec les enfants voilà ça se décline sur
tous les critères mais notamment sur la
plus grosse structure de coût de de ces
prestataires c'est vraiment les salaires
enfin c'est les les charges salariales
donc les charges de personnel donc si on
met plus de professionnels si on
mobilise des professionnels pour des
activités socio-éducatives si on
mobilise un psychologue pour avoir des
temps de supervision et cetera forcément
ça un coup donc ça c'est une vol c'est
une critérisation de la DSP et donc
c'est aussi une volonté politique de ne
pas juste se dire finalement avec les
crèches on peut afficher des créations
de place et donc répondre à la pression
des familles qui disent moi je veux des
solution sur ma commune mais de se dire
voilà je c'est j'ai besoin d'avoir des
des places de qualité donc c'est la
critérisation effectivement dans les
despect qui est qui est déterminante et
donc c'est une sensibilisation aussi à
des élus à à cette question après sur
l'aspect échelon ça rejoint les question
de Madame sur les échelons communaux et
et
départementaux
je pense que l'outil déjà encore une
fois des schémas si on si on a une offre
régulée sur un territoire on évite les
effets de concurrence et donc notamment
des concurrences agressives en matière
de prix donc ça évite une partie des
sujets ça permet aussi d'être
prescriptif sur bah de quoi a besoin le
territoire en terme de en terme de place
de l'inscrire dans le temps et donc de
mettre aussi tout l'appareil de
formation en lien avec ses besoins du
territoire parce qu' aujourd'hui quand
on interroge nous avons interrogé un
nombre de régions dans le casadre de la
mission on leur dit mais finalement
vous vous financez le la formation de X
éducateur de jeunes enfants où vont où
vont-ils travailler on est incapable de
nous le dire sauf à quelques rares
exceptions près et est-ce que c'est
suffisant ou pas suffisant personne
n'est capable de le dire et donc il y a
vraiment un travail encore une fois
systémique c'est dire de quoi on a
besoin sur un territoire est-ce qu'on a
besoin encore de nouveaux acteurs ou pas
et si i Dans quelle dans quelle quantité
et sur quel sujet est- que ce qui se
fait sur le médicosocial sur le
médicosocial il y a des besoins sur le
handicap et cetera tout ça c'est c'est
régulé par les ARS qui définissent des
plans des appels à projets et cetera
donc un réguler réguler l'offre et
mettre du coup en relation l'ensemble
des acteurs par rapport à cette ce
diagnostic partagé ces besoins partagés
et là on aura auà des questions de
est-ce qu'on modifier les compéten
obligatoire ou pas d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs déjà on aura un outil qui va
permettre d'être beaucoup plus virtueux
en terme d'appareil de formation de
qualité et d'éviter les effets de bord
que vous avez souligné sur les DSP ou
les effets de de mise en concurrence
d'acteurs ou ou ou de
prix vous vous sur la question des des
sur la question des missions vous avez
donc répondu qu'il y avait une mission
IGAS IGF qui était en cours euh en
fonction de la date de de rendu de cette
mission on sera peut-être amené au sein
de notre commission au sein de notre
commission d'enquête bah de pouvoir
entendre les les auteurs euh je précise
aussi qu'on a qu'il y a eu une mission
qui a elle été effectuée de la DGCCRF
sur les microocèches et là on les
écoutera la la semaine prochaine en tout
cas merci Madame et messieurs pour ces
réponses et je lève la
séance là
posezla merci monsieur le Président une
relance sur cette question des missions
de de contrôle puisque j'ai bien compris
la mission IGAS IGF mais si j'en ai bien
compris c'est sur le sujet des
microcèches voilà j'ai bien compris
aussi vous l'avez évoqué l'évolution
législative qui permettrait on le
souhaite tous de mieux contrôler les
groupes mais je repose ma question de
façon très concrète c'était une
recommandation de votre rapport une
mission de contrôle ciblée sur un ou
plusieurs groupes qui conduit à une
étude des comptes est-ce que à votre
connaissance voilà j'essaie de poser la
question la plus clairement possible
est-ce que à votre connaissance cette
mission de contrôle ciblée sur un ou
plusieurs groupes a été lancée merci la
parole est à vous répondez à la question
et et le compte-rendu notera la
réponse euh l'autorisation de procéder à
ce type de de contrôle est toute récente
c'est ça doit être du mois de décembre
je crois donc il aurait été difficile
qu'une mission puisse partir avant donc
c'est c'est prématuré par contre ça
devient envisageable voilà
merci pour cette réponse je lève la
séance et et je vous recevrez le
programme des auditions de la semaine
prochaine très bientôt puisqu'on attend
encore quelques réponses et je vous
remercie tous